viewer discretion is advised in part one
we learned what the H FS in principle is
and how social taboos affect the
profanity of a society now I want to
dive into American taboos and explore
how our taboos have changed over time
and how profanity has followed because
profanity has drastically changed with
slurs and words about group identity
quickly becoming the worst kinds of
profanity of this generation and we're
going to trace this change in profanity
through the lives of comedians people
who challenge taboos for a living
[Music]
and our story begins in 1961 when Lenny
Bruce is arrested for saying cocksucker
on stage now that name may fly over some
modern heads but at the time Lenny Bruce
was the biggest thing in comedy in
Rolling Stones best stand-ups of all
time
Bruce is number three on that list and
if comedy loves being on the edge then
Lenny was the guy dancing off cliffs his
comedy took on every American sacred cow
from race to sexual Puritanism and he
would say anything even if it got him
arrested and his whole life was full of
legal issues he was in and out of
courthouses for saying the wrong words
appealing and just dealing with a cold
legal system and obscenity laws all the
while he was whittling away eventually
dying in his home in 1966 four years
before New York's highest appellate
court would vindicate him of all charges
one of his prosecutors later said we all
knew what we were doing we used the law
to kill him and this is a pivotal moment
because even though America is
prosecuting comics for breaking taboos
there was also a shift taking place in
young people right around the 60s and
70s America has the sexual revolution in
the civil rights movement that totally
shake up the value system of America and
changed the taboos so ten years after
Bruce gets arrested another comedian
George Carlin is coming up similar
styles similar anti-authoritarian and a
similar fascination with bad words and
pushing the edge but this time the
culture has changed
so when Carlin performed seven words you
can't say on television which is loaded
with the worst profanity of the day it's
a huge success you know what I mean it's
just like we've decided there be some
whereas we won't say all the time and I
was just trying to find out which words
they were for sure all of them I wanted
a list and I wanted to know the ones
that you could never say on television I
mean the filthy words that are always
filthy and all I could think of was shit
piss fuck cunt cocksucker motherfucker
tits
he was just as provocative as Lenny
Bruce was except time had gone by and
the taboos of the older generation were
weakened the difference between Carlin
and Bruce was when they did the act
Carlin mentions this idea in an
interview Lenny and I had this language
in common and he broke he was the first
one to make language an issue and he
suffered for it I was the first one to
make a language an issue and to succeed
from it the lesson from George Carlin is
obvious in profanity and in comedy
timing is everything
but this cultural shift that Karlin
built a career on didn't stop there
HFS words have continued to weaken and
as good as Carlin's 'but was almost
fifty years later his list of dirty
words you can't say on television needs
an update because on TV and especially
on the internet you can say any of those
words that you want now don't we turn
this back around we stop being a con
that was Bob Bob had pitched it do you
give me a fucking creeps you know that
dick stuff
LT this is a waste of our damn time you
pissed me off San Francisco to recap
what Lenny Bruce got arrested for is
what Carlin got celebrated for and now
you can win Carlin's bad word bingo just
flipping through a few channels these
words are hardly taboo or forbidden at
all anymore in fact a study came out
that just over five years across all TV
networks the usage of traditional
profanity went up 69% and over 50 years
authors were 28 times more likely to
include traditional swearing in the
books they wrote so there's clear
empirical evidence that HFS words have
been normalized not that they're
completely harmless but they've been
robbed of most of their bite
HFS words in America are something like
the Queen of England there's still the
face of profanity but there's not much
power behind them
but while HFS words were being declawed
a special class of words became even
more toxic and unsalable than before
slurs the in words hate speech
microaggressions anything targeting
identity these became the new sacred cow
to replace the old you won't get fired
for saying fuck in the office but you
might get fired for saying the other F
word
now it's worth taking a moment to say
that slurs are different from other
types of profanity after all they
specially target groups unlike other bad
words ass is universal because everyone
has one but not everyone is a homosexual
so words like faggot seem much more
targeted
so perhaps slurs do deserve a special
place in our language that said there's
something about this profanity that I
don't like often we judge the word by
itself condemning syllables regardless
of situation Chris Rock noted this in an
interview saying why he stopped
performing at colleges because quote
they're way too conservative not in
their political views but in their
social views and in their willingness
not to offend anybody you can't even be
offensive on your way to being
inoffensive in other words even if you
have something wholesome to say you
better not use the no-no language on
your way to making that point he goes on
to mention someone else who also hated
the new profanity I remember talking to
George Carlin before he died in him
saying the exact same thing in fact he
is a bit about it there's a different
group to get pissed off at you in this
country for everything you're not
supposed to say can't say fruit can't
say faggot can't say queer can't say
Nancy boy can't say pansy can't say
nigger boogey jig jigaboo skinhead
jungle bunny Morley Mullin Janish matzo
there is absolutely nothing wrong with
any of those words in and of themselves
it's the intention behind the words that
makes them good or bad I get tired of
people talking about bad words and bad
language bullshit it's the context that
makes them
but despite that eloquent argument for
the total liberation of words I can't
help but think that Carlin lost his war
for total free speech even if he won his
battle for liberating a type of
profanity
because profanity is a human universal
deeply rooted in societal taboos and
though these taboos can shift with time
they never disappear entirely
so the profanity won't either it will
only change this has been the story in
America in the last 50 years we have
shifted from primarily in HFS culture to
primarily and in culture of swearing for
me this suggests that we don't get less
sensitive as much as we change what
we're sensitive about and this is
ultimately brought forward a few
questions in my mind what balance of
free speech and sensitivity towards
social issues do we want
given that taboos change over time how
can we recognize that words harm people
without capitulating towards an ideology
that condemns words outside of their
context and finally is it inevitable
that our kids will simultaneously think
we were being prudes and bigots only
time will tell I wish I had the words to
express this feeling that's been singing
in my chest and stomach is fluttering
when I hear your name all those
vibrations to hit drums are making some
soup
I love the cute things that we do
watching me write my lyrics and you
critique them too that's something you
never have to push your energy into you
said what I mean sir it's
thank you for watching that video number
one if you like that music go check out
Seneca B and Joey pecker ro number two
you liked the video go discuss it in the
comments below or go join us on discord
reddit twitter you know follow me
anywhere I will see you next week with
another video thanks
[Music]